in this video I want to talk about um
carbohydrates now you might be familiar
with carbohydrates and sometimes people
just call them sugars and I want to just
give a brief introduction to them so the
simplest carbohydrates are called
monosaccharides but before I get into
that I want to talk about the V sort of
formula for carbohydrates they're carbo
right which implies carbon hydrates
implies water so if we think about
carbohydrates they really are just
something that is like this CH 2 O n
which sort of is anything that has
carbons and waters in this sort of ratio
so it'll be cnh2n oh and so an example
of this that we're going to talk about
later is glucose which is just c6h12o6
and the simplest carbohydrates are
monosaccharides which is just um
basically just means one sugar
monosaccharides these are the simplest
sugars or simple sugars that can be
broken down further and we're going to
talk about them specifically in a later
video but I kinda wanna introduce
carbohydrates as a sort of concept first
when we think about carbohydrates we
normally think about the most basic one
being a glyceraldehyde which looks like
this I'm actually gonna show just a lot
I it looks like this glyceraldehyde
looks like this has CH 0 at the top I'm
drawing the Fischer projection to this
point see HOH and then a ch2oh now
glyceraldehyde has three carbons and it
has an aldehyde group up here so it is
therefore actually specifically an aldo
triose
okay Aldo because it has the the most
oxidized carbon at the top is a is an
aldehyde and triose meaning that it's a
three carbon sugar one two three there
another three carbon sugar is a
dihydroxyacetone dihydroxy acetone which
looks like this okay now this is also a
triose because it has three carbons but
it's a keto triose right the reason is
the key tail is because this carbon here
is a ketone right these hydroxy groups
are out here this is not an aldehyde is
a ketone because there are carbons on
either side of this carbon that spot
that's double bond to the oxygen so this
is a keto triose and just in general you
have aldoses and tripe and ketosis and
then usually have either it's if it's a
three carbon sugar it's a Mista triose
and then four carbons would be a tete
Rousse pentose four five hexose four six
and so on and so forth really anything
that ends in os-- is a sugar of some
sort okay oh s--- sugar or carp okay so
these this glyceraldehyde actually has
car chirality so if we draw up the
Fischer projection drawn out the Fischer
projection but I'm going to actually
right now for glyceraldehyde let's do
the Fischer projection so that we can
discuss so that we can discuss chirality
okay so you can draw glyceraldehyde the
simplest
monosaccharide like this okay this is
specifically d-glyceraldehyde whereas
the
is L glyceraldehyde now all we did was
just switch the H note on the OHP
remember with Fischer projections these
horizontal lines represent groups that
are coming out of the plane towards you
and then straight those should be the
vertical lines are implied to be going
backwards into the plane so we if you
recall D sugars are the ones that we're
concerned with when it comes to biology
they're the ones that exist in in in
life forms whereas L ll sugars are not
what we think about ll amino acids are
biological organisms but D sugars are
biological organisms so these two are
related and that they are enantiomers of
each other okay
these two are enantiomers okay and I
want to define enantiomers enantiomers
are our stereo isomers that differ in
absolute configuration at all chiral
centers okay so these two only have that
one chiral Center here and so they
differ in an absolute configuration
there and hence they are enantiomers
because they only have that one chiral
Center and again so most most natural
sugars are d sugars okay so now I want
to talk about so actually whenever we
draw sugars we think about the D with
the D sugars that have an OHA
the Oh H pointing to the right on the
last carbon before the ch2oh whoops ever
end up with the H on that carbon
on that ch2oh group there we go
so when the Oh H is on the right that's
what we think about when we think about
D sugars okay so um there are however
these things called diastereomers which
I'm sure you've heard the term before
what are diastereomers diastereomers
they are stereoisomers that differ in at
least one but not all stereocenters
differ differ in absolute configuration
to be specific okay so stereoisomers
that differ in absolute configuration
and at least one but not all
stereocenters okay because of the
differed at all the stereocenters that
is that they'd then be enantiomers okay
so let me give you a quick quick
examples here so if we had if we had
these four carbon sugars here if we had
for instance if we had this here okay if
we had this this is d erie throws okay
and we know that it's d because the o h
group here the oh HOH the last carbon
right from the top down is it so H
groups on the right so it's definitely a
D okay
so now this here would be Oh a CH o H
this here is L Erie throws because all
of the stereocenters right these two
here are exactly the opposite so they're
actually me
images of each other right so they are
enantiomers okay but what about these
well these are also four carbon
molecules or four carbon sugars
this here is d3 OHS okay notice how it
only differs from thierry throws in that
it's still it's still a d sugar right
because the Oh H is on the right side
this bottom row is right on the right
side but here it differs from a wreath
rose right so it's actually this is
actually a diastereomer of a wreath rose
okay but it has its own its own mirror
image which looks like this right which
is l 3 OS okay so these two are
enantiomers and these two are
enantiomers but this and this D 3 OS in
deep and deardiary throats and D 3 OS
are diastereomers le wreath rose and elf
Rios are also diastereomers okay and
keep in mind when it's on a glass tile
which is on the left side it's an L
sugar the last Oh H is on the right side
then it's a t-shirt okay so let's go
forth with a further example okay let's
think about glucose and galactose
because they are very important sugars
so we have draw glucose looks like this
it's a six carbon sugar so we have a CH
oh and then a ch2oh that's what those
are the two carbons and then in between
that we have one two three four four
carbons that have HS and OHS so glucose
looks like this
okay this is actually glucose and
specifically it's D glucose because this
last I which is on the right okay
now this here I'm going to draw is going
to be D galactose so even if you don't
know the structure of galactose you know
that the last carbon on the right is
going to have to be in LH however the
last carbon has to have the O H on the
right excuse me okay
so it actually looks like this okay so
now notice here these two only differ at
the one two three fourth carbon right
only at the fourth carbon do they differ
right you start the numbering at the
most oxidized carbon which is that one
so one two three four five six same
thing over here so these guys are are
diastereomers right because they differ
and at least one but not all of these
stereocenters right so these days are
diastereomers
but specifically specifically they are
epimers so let me scroll back up a
little bit to mention something epimers
are a specific class of diastereomers
that differ in absolute configuration at
only one chiral center right so glucose
and galactose are our epimers
specifically c4 epimer okay these two
all right now most of the time when it
comes to biochemistry it's easiest to
think about these sugars and actually a
different form other than the fisher
perch
we're going to think about is the
actually v d-- hayworth projections
which are circular structures so glucose
and galactose can both exist in linear
form but they can also exist in cyclic
forms which are called Haworth
projections so if we think about glucose
the way it's going to actually cyclize
actually let me draw it over here so let
me sort of title this now as Haworth
projections which is what we're going to
get into Haworth projections are sort of
drawn like this so let's say we again we
have glucose imagine glucose we have
glucose like this one two three four and
the ch2oh let's say we have d glucose
because separated from this stuff over
here okay if we have d glucose now what
ends up happening is that the way it's
like Liza's is like this so um if we
draw this we can draw it like this if
the the ring will begin to form like
this where here we're going to have the
aldehyde right the c1 here group okay
Ashley draw that a little bit
differently kinda looks like this okay
over here we have the uh no H group
specifically it's this Oh H group so let
me let me number these carbons to kind
of keep track of them to see one two
three oops I forgot to draw the hydrogen
here one two three four five and six so
carbon number five 0h right the one the
that we knew determines the D that's
this one here okay because this one's
going to be one this is going to be two
three four five and then six is actually
going to come up like this
ch2oh okay so that's the sixth carbon up
there okay so here on the fifth carbon
do age so now let me actually draw you
finish drawing all of these so we have
the H coming down here the HS are
actually implied so I'm not going to
draw all of them right actually I'll
draw them why not right but if I don't
draw them it's implied that there's an H
there okay so anyways what happens here
is that there are electrons on this Oh H
group here this one here right and they
can attack nucleophilically this carbon
now they can attack from either the top
or the bottom of this and the reason why
is because this here this carbon is sp2
hybridized and you can remember sp2
hybridized means a trigonal planar
geometry right and if it's a planar
structure then you can top attack from
the top of the plane or the bottom of
the plane so when this when this
d-glucose cyclize is okay this is still
deep blue goes here we form we can form
one of two things okay so if it attacks
let's see we can either get this
structure so all of this stuff right 6 5
4 3 2 all that stuff stays the same
ok and again I'm not going to draw these
for this in this case I'm not going to
draw the hydrogen's just to save space
but now we're going to have an O age
group here if it attacks from the top of
the plane we get this fit the O H
pointing up okay but if we attack from
the bottom of the plane
we get all this stuff is the same first
of all we get this now we've don't the
only way these two molecules differ is
right here at this carbon here this
carbon here is the only carbon at which
these two differ and stereochemistry now
this carbon is called the anomeric
carbon right so an immerse animals are a
specific type of whoops they are a
specific type of epimer right because it
differ only I want and specifically at
this carbon right this is a these two
are enemies this one in which the Oh H
and the ch2oh on the same side is the
beta anomer
okay so this would actually be called
specifically beta-d-glucose and this
when the Oh H is trans to the ch2oh this
one's up and this one's down right when
they're on opposite sides of the of the
Ring this would be the alpha anomer
okay so now these two oh the way they're
related is these are an immerse which is
a specific type of epimer that exists
only when these things are drawn in the
Haworth projections which is this here
right so once the ring forms you're
either going to have the beta version or
the alpha version of the Alpha enema or
the beta anomer
of the particulars sugar okay so that's
all I wanted to say in this video in the
next video we'll be talking about
specific monosaccharides and the ones
that I think you should be familiar with
thanks for watching